in the wake of the LAPD shooting many of
you are asking do black lives matter
into you I say that's a stupid question
and I won't respond to it so when the
LAPD shooting happened the narrative was
set officers kill unarmed homeless black
man right that's what we knew but when
you actually look at the video which was
even available to the press at that time
there's clearly a lot more to the story
than that knowing even more now that the
victim was actually an illegal alien and
a convicted bank robber at what point do
we say okay let's just wait for the
facts to come in on a story that
involves police brutality before we try
them in a jury of public opinion listen
I get there some cops out there who
abuse their power
absolutely and I'm sure there are some
racist cops who don't give some black
kids in this country a fair shake this
is not one of those cases let's roll the
tape okay right off the bat that guy
tried to swing at a cop as hard as
humanly possible it was Mike Tyson in
his prime coming off of his feet kind of
a haymaker now I could just be my white
male priviledge would never think about
swinging at a cop let alone referring to
him as anything other than sir sir sir
what are you about Kolya
oh I understand that swinging at a cop
could be hazardous to my health okay
let's just start this off you're police
officer going into Skid Row where
assaults on officers tripled from 2006
to 2008 186 major violent crimes in the
first six months of 2014 and half of all
women at Skid Row have experienced
sexual assault the Marley's were dead to
begin with cops go down here this guy's
out of his mind
he assaults cops they tried to tase him
before this first clip of the video he
still got back up swung at them and then
allegedly reached for a cop's gun by the
way who was black let's watch some more
of the altercation
okay now that little one grabbed the
cops nightstick you can hear the cop
yelling get my stick get my stick get my
stick now look at her body language and
what she does next but do you think that
this little person is going to a kindly
give the officer back his nightstick he
take the nightstick to a safe location
until the altercation passes then notify
the proper authorities or see the mother
with is oh nice let's go to the body
language here oh it looks like it was
see before the cops subdued the
perpetrator which I'm sure was very mean
and unnecessary and after this you can
see that the gentleman reached for one
of the officers gun allegedly the black
officer so now who's the racist the
black perper the black cop at which
point he was shot something that really
bothers me as everybody just says
unarmed as though that's the only focus
in these cases and when they say unarmed
by the way what they really mean is they
don't have a gun firstly do you have any
idea how easy it is to kill or maim or
blind someone without a gun
more people are murdered with knives and
body parts than rifles 57 officers have
been shot by unarmed suspects
since the year 2000 many unarmed
suspects become armed by taking a cop's
own gun and using it against him as far
as hitting a cop in the back of a head
with a nightstick every five minutes
someone dies from a head injury more
people are killed with hammers and clubs
than guns so the idea that a cop can
only defend his life if you have a gun
cocked loaded and aimed at his face is
ridiculous and the idea that America is
inherently racist because we believe
that cops should have the right to
protect their life is also ridiculous
especially when you consider the fact
that one of the officers here was black
as a matter of fact 17% of the LAPD are
black Americans are they all racist or
they all turncoats well they say that
here in the video
don't you think that many American cops
including the black cops might be more
sensitive in the wake of Mike Brown and
Eric garner to be careful right now and
don't you think there are probably a lot
of criminals out there who think cops
are afraid to pull the trigger and
running scared and maybe might try and
take advantage of that wouldn't get a
guy with last time would you with all
that being included into the scenario if
a cop cannot shoot back to defend his
own life in this scenario I can't
imagine one where he ever would be able
to but maybe that's just racism again
discounting the black cop or some kind
of pro cop propaganda you let me know
the most important takeaway here is
after Mike Brown and garner and this
just wait for the facts to come in so
you can make an informed decision and
not look like an idiot
congratulations America I just saved you
a whole bunch of embarrassment hey if
you like this video subscribe or watch
this previous video right next to me if
you don't you're probably a racist who
hates black cops